[Music]
carnival goers have unfurled their wings
again in notting hill we are so excited
to be back i think carnival is an
institution in britain it's a cultural
institution so to not have it for three
years has been really really difficult
um so with all what's going on in the
world the cost of living crisis what was
climate crisis to be back here in a
cultural form that brings people
together is means so much to us
the air is filled with steel drums body
paint and the smell of jerk chicken
it's been a celebration of caribbean
culture since the 60s
[Music]
and now is a chance for people to put
lockdown behind them
get involved in nothing else carnival
you know it's for everybody remember
it's a caribbean-based event but it's
for everyone it's good to be back and um
i know things look great but guess what
have some fun think positive and it'll
get better
sunday is family day at carnival
the biggest costumes and the biggest
crowds but
as you can hear the party is already
starting to heat up
it's the largest carnival in europe and
could be london's largest yet with 2
million people expected over the weekend
there will also be thousands of police
one aspect of the years of planning the
mayor of london says has gone into the
event
a lot of planning takes place to make
sure carnival is as safe as it can be
with up to two million people obviously
it's an opportunity for criminals for
organized gangs and so forth so the
organizers the police city hall the
community works really hard to make
carnival safe
the party continues and the london
streets are vibrating with the dancing
of millions of feet
madeleine ratchcliffe sky news in
notting hill